Hello Freak bitches.
What do you do with your time these days?
Like what's a typical day for Hixon Gracie?
Um,
right now I back to teach in Crohn's place because I wanted to,
to have him march dcis,
stress with the,
how they academy goes.
So I pick two times a week to teach.
They're giving defense glasses at this point.
Before that I was doing seminars once a month at the most,
once,
twice every couple of months to to make my living.
And also because I feel like the best things in life,
money cannot buy.
And I feel like the quality of my,
my,
my meals that the way I eat,
the way my relationship,
my sleep,
those are very,
very viable.
A sets,
you know,
plus the time I have to do things I love to do.
That's kind of when this is fuel.
Like when I feel like I'm everything.
So I feel like I'm happy enough to be my best at service because I always tried
to be at service helping somebody with Jujitsu with knowledge.
We from nutrition with breathing,
you know,
it's not about the price is about the,
the service,
you know?
And then I put my head in the and said,
yeah,
I knew I'd have a nice day.
I make a good speech with Joe Hogan.
I have a nice talk with Bravo was great day.
So somehow in a purpose for the federation.
So I always try to be positive,
but I have no schedule fixed.
Like I have to wake up vote you wouldn't know because at this point I create a
lifestyle which make me feel good to engage in different elements like this
federation now and having glasses on crowns and be here to be full of energy.
You know,
because sometimes you don't notice,
but based on your,
your,
your commitments,
your obligation,
you'll becoming more like a Robert and you,
you lose the perspective of what you need to be at your best.
And if you lose that perspective,
even though you still doing your routine,
sometimes you just minus you just 80 70 60% of what you should be.
So you're not going to be the best husband,
you're not going to be the best father,
the best employer,
the best employee,
you just,
you know,
it was just,
so at this point I feel like I have to be at my best physically do my,
if I feel like I have to stretch,
they're going to stretch,
breed,
joke,
have fun,
listen buddy,
whatever.
You know.
And then when I feel like,
man,
I'm so happy I could not eat so and then I can go and do my service,
you know?
And no,
because the window of life is smaller now for me is becomes,
I don't have too much time,
so I don't waste time to do what people expect from me.
I try to do things,
I read the relevant to my soul,
like this federation now I use I when I dream,
I don't dream small.
I dream like I make like a very space for a few days.
The biggest dream I can ream and I see that you know that level of of need for
the community and the level of of position.
I have to be the reference for that shift in the direction of our culture,
in our knowledge.
I feel like I could not be more motivated,
more happy to engage on this.
So,
and that's always life is about is just do your best and,
and,
and be excited to be motivated to,
to,
to the next day.
There's such a refreshing attitude,
your attitude,
your,
your philosophy on life because I think it's very easy and I've been,
I've trapped myself in it sometimes where you concentrate too much.
I'm making money,
concentrate too much on being ambitious and you forget the quality of life.
Yes.
You are focuses almost entirely on your quality of it.
You know,
because like I said man,
how much cost your motivation,
how much costs your friends,
how much cost your health,
how much cost,
your intelligence,
those things is priceless.
I mean if you take those off your life,
you take,
you're more vision of your life.
It can be Bill Gates can be the biggest.
So if you,
if you ask me if I want to have bill gates life,
I don't know.
I don't know him.
So it's not a based on his bank account is based on how happy he is,
how horny he is,
how,
you know,
how motivated he is to wake up and do his thing.
He don't look too horny.
I don't think
so.
So that's,
that's a very essential thing,
which sometimes sleep to people's fingers and,
and the priorities in the daily,
you know,
in the payments and say put you in a role where uh,
I feel like,
um,
if you tell me in the past what's the core age,
what's the opposite of courage?
I want to say cowardness because either you tough enough to challenge and to
fight or to or in their new car and then you chicken out.
So that's in the past was like the,
the,
the opposite of,
of,
of college is very high to remember this in those days.
And I believe the opposite of it should they use conformity,
you know,
is people get conformed.
Oh,
I don't like my wife the way I used to like,
but I'm never going to divorce because I'm afraid to lose my house or the
situation is so established so I got to keep,
so I don't like this job,
but they're going to keep here because better than his.
So in,
in,
in all the hands of the few,
if you get quiet on that kind of compromise to,
to maintain because you afraid to risk,
let's keep you like one step behind from you,
follow your heart,
follow the ambition.
You should 18 years old,
you don't think twice.
Like I say,
Hey,
let's go to Australia.
You think,
okay,
let's go boom.
But when you fifth 50 sales,
yeah,
what are you going to do there?
Maybe I'm going to,
so it's different,
you know,
and that's kind of hate or what are we going?
Yes.
So that's kind of pretty much where keep you from be at your best because if you
willing to sacrifice,
if you're willing to broke new,
new challenges,
if you really chew you in the stage of liveliness and,
and excitement and unpredictability,
who make you feel like you're in heaven,
you know,
every time I was engaging in a compromise or a fight was something that I thank
you.
Like I have my routines prior to fight.
One of them is edit day off my fight.
I wake up and I thank you.
Glad to be alive and I acknowledge how perfect we'll be that day.
If I die today,
say fuck my wasn't,
there'd be a perfect day if I die because I have,
you know,
I accomplished my think I'm in my mission,
I representing my family.
So I don't go that you tap,
I go there to die.
Like I have to kill me.
It's not,
I'm never going at that.
So by,
that's not a sport like orientation,
this is a philosophical,
uh,
owner representation,
you know,
is not something I teach.
My snow should not that,
no,
it's not like that.
It's about how I feel,
how I feed my kids,
how I follow my tradition.
So in engagement,
I am not going to be the one who going to quit.
Then I have to cure me,
my brother,
he can throw the Tao.
But for me is unacceptable.
You know,
I do give up from my life.
So based on that kind of spiritual guidance,
my life is very intense.
My life is very,
I mean directed to accomplish give up is not an option.
You know,
I can,
I can direct my,
my,
my focus,
I can give up from something to go somewhere else,
but I never will give up from something because I feel like I cannot reach
there.
I may say,
okay,
that's not for me.
I go somewhere else.
But if I still focus,
I will take those falls.
I will take those obstacles as a motivation to just set up a new strategy to try
again.
You know,
I'm very competitive in a sense.
I like the perfection of things.
So this is like a,
a situation where put you in a situation where you will have no,
either you go forward or you don't,
you don't stay in the middle.
Don't say just waiting for people are waiting for more.
Those are kinds of things going to stack you back in life and,
and just make you feel like best through life.
As you know,
if you haven't,
you know,
you irrelevant,
is is very weak.
[inaudible]
yeah.